pop
[Musique]
la dame très sérieuse va faire
l'interview prise de tête
c'est bien non je ne sais pas ce que va
être le gage le cap et demain soir je
sais pas quel prix je leur ai payé mais
il a cherché à prêcher un profil de
l'apec tu as ce soir-là prend des
vacances même qui va chier manos
vient alors à se prendre un peu la tête
sur des sujets sérieux julien clerc est
ce que vous êtes favorable au droit de
vote pour les immigrés j'avais averti
ses prises de tête oui oui même s'il ya
des gens qui payent des impôts en france
non pas le voile à penser que les
assassins d'enfants mérite la peine de
mort alors ça évidemment c'est un c'est
une question que je me pose plus ce
n'est pas ce que j'ai
j'ai fait une chanson moi là dessus sur
la peine de mort est évidemment c'est un
débat terrible et je devrais vous
répondre au nom puisque jeu quand on est
contre la peine de mort on est contre la
peine de mort est en même temps quand on
a des enfants
oui on a envie de de penser le contraire
voilà mais enfin disons que je suis
contre la peine de mort je continue de
l'être si l'un de vos proches souffrait
d'un mal incurable est-ce que vous soyez
favorables à l'euthanasie si la personne
en expriment le besoin
évidemment si elle le mentionne si elle
le demande c'est le réclament
oui l'avortement l'avortement je suis
évidemment pour l'avortement
simplement je crois que c'est par
exemple je crois qu'il faut essayer de
tout faire pour en arriver là
voilà mais sinon c'est un droit c'est
une nécessité c'est savez de même moi
j'ai toujours pensé que c'était les
femmes qui décident et d'avoir les
enfants et bien elles peuvent décider
aussi le contraire on peut en avoir
ça c'est un droit absolument qui ne
devra pas discuter est ce que vous êtes
favorable à l'adoption d'enfants par dés
couples homosexuels
je pense que les enfants ont besoin
d'amour
mais en même temps c'est vrai que on
peut réfléchir à ça on peut on peut lire
j'ai vu des filles magnifiques déjà
enfin le très joli film d'actualité là
dessus je réfléchirai avant mais si vous
me demandez de mettre un bulletin
dans l'urne je crois qu'on finirait par
dire oui je suis si vous pensez que
c'est un crime contre soi même c'est un
droit je pense qu'il faut vachement de
courage moi je suis cité mais si on est
contre la peine de mort je vois pourquoi
on pourrait s'appliquer à soi non mais
de toute façon le suicide c'est quand
quelqu'un celui-ci c'est qu'il est trop
mal qu'il ya des choses qui ne peut plus
regarder ce qu'il peut plus vivre des
choses qui employait des mots simples de
la langue française qui ne supportent
plus tout simplement décision enfin les
autres nous notre pas là dedans on n'a
pas à juger ce à quoi répond dieu vous
j'aimerais bien par moments ça serait
plus facile en particulier dans votre
dans votre questionnaire quand on croit
en dieu on a d un chemin tout tracé le
nom malheureusement alors je jeu j'aime
beaucoup les gens qui croient qu'une
union qui ont la foi
en même temps j'ai été heureux de fin
heureuse
j'étais je ne nie pas j'ai été élevé là
dedans on le même si on pratiquait pas
beaucoup enfin en d'autres termes j'ai
été heureux de marier à l'église quand
le moment était venu de 2,2 me marier je
pars à l'église tous les dimanches mais
je suis issu de cette culture l'âme et
j'admire les gens qui croient en moi
malheureusement vous y croyez pas
lorsque dans un truc bien dit j'y crois
pas et même quand l'avion commence un
peu à bouger comme ça j'ai d'une croix
toujours pas quoi oui non c'est à dire
gg
non mais c'est moi et je mets ça serait
se renier ou se met à prier tous et vous
êtes en ligne
j'essaie toujours et j'essaie d'être
cohérent à peu près égale vous dans
l'avion bouge toi là tu vas me met à
prier c'est un exercice confère un peu
hésitant il est dans un avion c'est le
test en ciel baisse de la région qui
bouge avec ce n'est pas non plus dans la
violence que pascal a inventé son pari
avait pris l'avion
oui là encore besoin pascal lui disait
tu te mets à genoux tu pries et un jour
tu croiras c'est autre chose on va faire
une interview prise de tête
on bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien alors justement à continuer à se
prendre la tête là imaginez vous faites
un enfant une fille je ne vous en faites
à une autre fille alors est-ce que vous
lui demandé d'avorter
ça dépend si j'ai dit si j'ai 18 ans et
que j'ai pas de thunes pour le faire
vivre et que je sais que j'ai des
problèmes de ravir j'ai pas de pas de
boulot pas l'intérêt 50 ans des
milliardaires à leur tour être combien
d'heures je garde d'accouchement ce
canton bière d'orge de votre mère est
atteinte d'une maladie incurable et vous
demandent l'euthanasie
oui non je suis moi je pourrais pas le
faire parce que c'est ma mère mais je
comprendrais qu'elles veulent
si elle souffre trop que veut arrêter ça
vous laisserai les toubibs le faire si
elles demandent si elle me regarde et me
dit oh il faut trouver une solution bien
joué par la loi lagarde et à faire
sauter la garder à souffrir quoi moi je
n'ai toujours pas mr sur la boîte
aujourd'hui je voyais avec les piètres
donna vous fait toujours le sourire si
la voie dans un lit d'hôpital et kate
demande un truc je pense que ça peut
être entre guillemets humain de craquer
je pense quand même parce que s'ils pas
laisser souffrir sa mère c'est quand
même un type type a violé et tué trois
gamines de
11 ans peine de mort pas peine de mort
c'est difficile je suis chez un peu
contre la peine de mort mais comme si
ces méga mensah se couche pour aller
tuer tout ça ouais donc ouais non mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai si si si si ton
enfant et que tu vois quelqu'un qui
abusent et enfin qui est tout petit
enfant que tu aimes tu peux aller faire
des choses de fou vous avez des amis
homosexuels c'est un jeu de l'esprit qui
est envisage qui envisage qui envisagent
d'adopter un enfant
boulouart conseillé de le faire vous
leur dites que c'est pas bien alors dit
que c'est pas bien
vous croyez en dieu vous je crois en
dieu
si vous deviez différentes façons de
prix ouais si vous deviez choisir une
religion vous choisiriez laquelle
peut-être la religion musulmane parce
qu'elle colle plus avec
avec quand tu roules tout simplement
content représente jésus blond aux yeux
bleus
ouais je suis noir plutôt l'islam plutôt
nice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien alors répondre brièvement sur des
sujets graves
c'est bien jean marie c'est bien
religieux c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles je vous admire c'est que vous
ne bougez pas par le single bien êtes
vous favorable à la sexualité hors
mariage bah oui parce que on est on est
pas à l'abri et puis des fois c'est bien
de deux peut-être des fois de toucher
une autre peau une autre paire de
nichons notre choupinette nos traders un
truc comme ça donc vous êtes vous êtes
favorable à la sexualité hors mariage
je suis favorable jeu jj set je suis un
pauvre je suis un pauvre humeur je pense
que faut pas engueulé sans son mari qu
dans la veste eu retrouve un préservatif
chaud ça nul de faire une scène à son
mari parce que trompé sa femme avec un
préservatif c'est une petite bêtise
trompé sa femme sans préservatif c'est
une grosse connerie et donc je dis moi
j'ai les couilles en tout cas de dire
bah moi que je pars en tournée ma femme
me prépare ma valise à me mets mes
chemises mes chaussettes me slip qui
elle même une petite boîte de
préservatifs et pourtant je ne trompe
jamais ma femme mais c'est pour le cas
il est favorable au divorce
je sais que ça peut arriver et si si
jamais c'est nécessaire bien sûr il faut
il faut le faire en ce qui me concerne
moi j'aime bien l'idée dans ma vie à moi
de mettre marié avec une femme et de ne
jamais la quitter jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours pour moi je trouve que c'est plus
+ samouraï quoi c'est plus
bien est-ce que vous êtes favorable
adoptions d'enfants par dés couples
homosexuels relance pas la team à
telenor au téléphone
non non non non oui mais non maintenant
je peux développer un petit peu parce
que maintenant il ya un truc qui est
formidable avec le pack si jamais tu dis
par exemple que tu es contre le pacs tu
passe pour un homme femme tout le monde
fuit dans son froc on veut pas être
homophobe
moi je suis pas homophobe vous trouvez
peut-être que l'homosexualité était plus
sexy du temps où elle était sulfureux
c'était plus sexy jean genet que les
petits couples qui vont faire les
courses ensemble chez auchan de matin
non je dis simplement que la république
n'importe quel gouvernement ou en tout
cas la république en général n'a pas
validé ce n'est pas le travail de la
république de valider une tendance
sexuelle ce n'est pas un troisième sexe
d'être homosexuel ça concerne d'ailleurs
à 80% les hommes déjà faut le dire c'est
pas un truc qui concerne à la fois les
attaques et simplement j'ai dit en
déconnant à tous mes copains homosexuel
je leur dis tous les jours on n'en
dormira un enfant tu sais en lui disant
et le prince charmant embrassa le prince
charmant
il ne se marier repas ils n'eurent pas
d'enfant puisqu'il se bourrer r le cul
or jours mais ils vécurent heureux je
suis dit je n'ai rien
ouais je n'ai rien du tout vraiment
encore une fois je le répète parce que
c'est hyper dangereux de parler de ça
parce que c'est la vieille crainte
d'être de se retrouver homophobes non le
trou de balle c'est une zone érogène
formidable et tout quand on passe un peu
le doigt sur le trop de mal c'est génial
ça peut même défaut de sauver d'une demi
mal donc moi je suis pas du tout ennemi
du dialogue au contraire bien mais ça
s'est fait à la alors marc toujours
qu'est ce qui arrive je voulais la
réaction de vie des voix c'est ce que
vous êtes pour l'adoption d'enfants par
dés couples homosexuels
bien sûr et puis n'est-ce pas à la
république a décidé de quoi que ce soit
je te parle d'amour quand on parle
d'enfants mahfoud à la république ce qui
dit non mais non pas des nouvelles des
enfants en ont à [ __ ] de république la
république elle n'a pas à défendre une
tendance doit instaurer une tangente sur
un môme je vais pas me poser la question
de ce que la république est d'accord à
ce que le bon dieu est d'accord à ce que
est ce que machin est d'accord on s'en
fout de la république si on est les
enfants on s'en fout un enfant ils ont
été pris en train à mon avis doit être
élevée entre un homme et une femme c'est
quand même le mieux pour moi c'est là
c'est la normalité
parce que je dis pas que d'être aussi ça
c'est anormal je n'ai que c'est une
originalité d'accord interpréteront ça
peut être mieux ça que c'est le gamin il
est avec deux pas en compte comme les
valises et de mec
deux êtres fantastiques peut-être que là
dans ce cas précis ça peut être mieux
bien sûr je moi je parle pas là on parle
de théories évidemment on est sur le sur
le papier sur le papier je dis que
l'épanouissement d'un enfants élevés par
deux hommes je pense que c'est moins
bien qu'un homme et une femme
j'ai le droit de penser ça commence bien
sûr bien alors jean marie en continu
l'interview prise vas-y vas-y continue
l'avortement pour moi l'âme n'est pas
arrivé dans le foetus avant au moins six
mois et il n'y a pas une destruction
d'une personne c'est un c'est un embryon
pour ceux qui pensent qu'ils ont détruit
une personne je pense pas que ce soit le
cas ça n'est pas suffisamment formés
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas
sortir un bébé du ventre de sa mère à
deux mois et le faire vivre parce qu'il
n'a pas d'existence encore l'euthanasie
l'euthanasie je suis contre parce que je
pense que
il faut même si les souffrances sont
terribles je pense qu'il faut les vivre
jusqu'au bout et que comme je crois pas
au hasard encore une fois je pense que
il ya 10 à différents cas de figure il
ya des gens par exemple la technique
peut permettre de rester de laisser
brancher quelqu'un et de le faire vivre
même contre savent c'est à dire que
naturellement il n'aurait pas vécu et il
serait mort donc après le fait de
débrancher quelqu'un qui a le cerveau
totalement mort c'est très différent
mais je parle l'euthanasie c'est à dire
donner la mort c'est pas retirer un
médicament ces différends ont retiré un
truc qui fait vivre c'est différent de
donner la mort mais donner la mort non
la peine de mort pour les assassins
enfants dès qu'on dit le mot enfant tout
le monde a envie de tuer tout le monde
si on tue ton enfance où tes yeux la
peine de mort tu vas pas attendre que
les jurés délibèrent tu vas mettre
suscita un pistolet dans la main tu vas
tu risques de la donner la mort
effectivement dans tous les cas de
figure je peux je pourrai jamais dire
que je cautionne la mort est encore une
fois comme le pacs quand c'est la loi
qui décide de dire voilà on va prendre
tel individu et on va le tuer ouais
c'est injouable
personne ne peut voter une loi comme ça
en revanche ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord
pour tout le monde mais une grosse
majorité des gens sont d'accord que
quand il ya des otages pris dans un
avion tu as des mecs du gign ils seront
avec une paire de couilles énorme comme
ça et qui on rend hommage d'ailleurs il
rentre il canarde et y tue les mecs et
tout le monde dit bravo
et là il n'ya pas de tribunaux ya rien
du tour décide de la peine de mort un
mec rentrent dans une école barre des
dynamiques comme à neuilly rentrons
lui-même ballan citron et moi
j'applaudis bas on a voté la peine de
mort on est tous d'accord
à part quelques trous du cul qui dit on
aurait peut-être pu le garder en vie les
mois mais moi moi je dis non parce que
moi je dis que si un mec rentrent dans
une maternelle avec un paquet dynamite
sur lui si ce mec risque la vie de
trente enfants qu'il risque pour moi sa
vie et personne ne me contredira en
disant que depuis l'attaqué qui a été
fait sur l'avion ya plus jamais de
détournement il y en avait
il y en avait 1 tous les tous les six
mois il y en a pu parce que on se dit
merde si je fais ça c'est la mort sûre
et certaine
donc je suis partagé entre les deux je
ne la gamme sonnerait pas je ne dirais
pas qu'il faut aller la donner mais en
revanche la loi c'est très très dur
parce que ce qui est écrit encore une
fois c'est exactement le thème de ce
qu'en disait tout à l'heure ce qui est
écrit n'est pas valable
il ya une loi pour chaque situation que
le mec ce jeudi un mec qui piquent trois
pizzas entendu ça ipic
si tu fais trois délits d'un certain
d'inde entre certains états des états
unis trois fois le même délit perpétuité
c'était assez un sketch si je me mets
avec le nom on fait un sketch et dessus
le mec qui piquent trois pizzas y prend
perpétuité il ya un juge avec des mecs
qui sont là le juge y rentrer chez lui
dit à sa femme chérie j'ai fait mon
travail aujourd'hui il ya un mais qu'il
avait piqué trois pizzas gmi perpète
et tout le monde regarde dans le plus
grand pays du monde c'est à dire que ce
rôle ilic ont le même cécile prend une
quiche
il échappe
il échappe à perpète il peut nommer
en plus si je mets si jamais ils veulent
les trois pizzas d'un coup et leurs
congés les deux pour lui ça il fera
pareil le préjudice est le même pour le
mec il va pas en prison
comment est-ce qu'on peut cautionner
les lois comme ça c'est la loi du coeur
qui fonctionne et c'est comme ça que
j'essaye de répondre à tes [ __ ] de bon
la légalisation de l'année la
légalisation des drogues douces vous
demande pas si vous êtes d'accord
la légalisation des drogues douces ah
oui oui oui bien sûr alors j ai la
libération de boys papon alors la
libération de maurice papon c'est à
mourir de rire
moi j'aimais bien badinter je laime plus
maintenant un balle à terre il nous dira
papon et les vieux et tout c'est pas
utile de laisser en prison dont il écrit
mme crimes contre l'humanité 1
ce mec vous verrez dans le crime contre
l'humanité il ya crime ya aussi humanité
ouais non mais oui d'accord mais
seulement ce mec
on aurait préféré l'enfermer quand il
était jeune on aurait très mal et on l'a
eue de vieux baron lancèrent monsieur on
leur ferme vieux et malade et en plus
on l'en faire brûler son servait et en
plus j'ai donc que c'est vachement sympa
d'être en prison vieux et malade
oui ce qui était à l'infirmerie tu
gâches pathé vaise année c'est mieux
mais ça veut dire quoi de libérer un mec
ça veut dire que bon bah c'est fini non
non non c'est pas possible il faut se
garder en prison à moi je pense pour le
gardent en prison il a failli les juger
il prend des années de prison mexico à
l'histoire
quand un gars s'ils veulent un scooter
on le colle en le collant saison quand
un mec il a il a tué une autre personne
et tout bas on le met en prison aussi et
puis si c'est un homme d'affaires qui
gruge des trucs bas aussi et le fils
mitterrand comme madame mitterrand elle
dit j'ai payé la rançon la rançon moi
j'aurais demandé 15 millions - la rampa
n'y a pas de rançon le mec on lui
reproche pas l'autre joué et j'entends
le visiter en dire il me regarde avec de
la haine dans les yeux ils te regardent
comme il veut qu est ce que tu en avant
les sites à rien est reproché il peut
être regardée comme il a bien sûr donc
et donc ce juge moi je le trouve je
trouve génial j'ai je crois je le trouve
génial parce que même pierre botton j'ai
vu une interview lui aussi je les
trouvais formidable parce que les divas
comment il vous a enfermé vous êtes tout
prix et où il dit ouais mais au bout du
compte je pense qu'il m'a remis sur les
sur les rails et n'a jamais attaqué pour
quelque chose que c'est tout le monde
nous
bouge pas pendant vous saviez tout le
monde a jugé serge si je remets le
chapeau ou bougeait pas ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
franchement thierrée ça te dirait pas de
pétanque
[Applaudissements]
oui je suis maso combat parce qu'il faut
être maso pour mettre un chapeau pareil
ça vaut quand même avec une mauresque et
des boules ça passe très bien
il faut aimer être soumis pour mettre ça
voyez vraiment assez le chapeau de la
soumission là c'est parce qu'on venait à
quoi fait bien fait romuald ça va mais
cheveux bien donc un stand prise de tête
des deux prêtres la violer est ce que
vous êtes je sais pas des questions
compliquées c'est juste votre avis est
ce que vous êtes favorable au divorce
bah oui bien sûr oui bien sûr
ben non mais si la question se pose si
déjà la question se pose c'est que ça va
ça n'a pas aller très bien donc idées
fortes quoi bon vous êtes favorable au
divorce
je suis pas favorable au divorce si les
gens ont déjà ils ont décidé de se
marier et ben s'imposer favorable ouais
voilà
voici déjà il se pose la question c'est
la wii est ce que vous êtes favorable à
la fidélité dans le couple
ça c'est pareil moi forcément si on me
demande
bah oui pour moi oui pour les autres
c'est ça les regarde érection toute
manière là quand je dis tout ça non moi
je dis tout ça ça veut rien dire non
mais s'apprête à chaque fois différent
non mais c'est vous qui nous intéressait
oui non mais d'accord mais même moi
voilà par exemple on peut le mari je
détruis depuis dix ans avec quelqu'un et
puis je laime vraiment mais qu'en même
temps bas enfin on peut jamais savoir
quoi c'est bête mais c'est bien prise de
tête en tout cas moi c'est l'interview
prise de tête ça c'est galère gens sont
pas déçus chez eux
est ce que vous êtes favorable à
l'adoption d'enfants par dés couples
homosexuels dans les corridas pourquoi
tant des corridas l'adoption les enfants
regroupés les sujets un peu brûlants
comme ça on va gagner 20 minutes cette
manière
tandis que ce soit des homosexuels pas
des courses et des conquois et vous
anthony camou choc que des couples
homosexuels puissent adapter des enfants
ça vous choque pas écoutez c'est
difficile d'y répondre - personnes
personnellement au départ comme ça je
suis contre si on doit dire pour ou
contre je dirais contre après il ya un
grand débat là dessus
est ce qu'un enfant sera plus malheureux
en maison de est enfin là d'un souhait
ce qui sera plus malheureux avec des
parents là on le sait pas mais c'est
après il ya tout un débat mais c'est
vrai que sur le principe vous êtes
content c'est évidemment tout le monde
va dire la même chose il vaut mieux
avoir des parents homosexuels sympa que
des parents hétérosexuels conquête c'est
un débat alors isild l'avortement êtes
pour ou contre l'euthanasie la natation
vous tenez dans une centrale nucléaire
un groupe toujours les sujets auxquels
la peine de mort j'imagine que vous êtes
contre la peine de mort comme nous tous
mais est-ce que vous êtes contre la
peine de mort pour les assassins
d'enfants
ben en fait par exemple
si c'est mon enfant que du glay la peine
de mort où qu'il aille en prison pour
moi c'est pas être ici je veux tu mois
après que ce soit quelqu'un d'autre qui
le tue bon j'aurais envie de les tuer
moi mais à vous le feriez s'est dévoilée
ça dépend des circonstances mais sans
doute pas c'est un enfant qui a tué un
autre en se rasant mais là ya pas de
problème à l'enfant que j'allais trois
enfants ils savent qu'il faut rater les
prises de tête moi gbh échoue
vous allez voir on va faire une
interview prise de tête on ne compte
dans le bush pendant le single
[Musique]
j'ai beau bon alors un tabou prise de
tête
c'est votre punition êtes vous favorable
au divorce
oui si ça ça me pose ni à la liberté
sexuelle dans le couple oui à
l'homosexualité à l'adoption d'enfants
par dés couples homosexuels à
l'avortement oui à l'euthanasie
ça semble poser au suicide si ça semble
poser si oui à la peine de mort pour les
assassins d'enfants
oui et est ce que vous êtes favorable
couloir de bus pas du tout
c'est bon
les gens ils sont pour l'avortement le
suicide et l'euthanasie sous les
couleurs de but j'avais quand vous êtes
une fille sérieuse la tête sur les
épaules vous faire une interview
sérieuse voilà ou alors sérieusement pas
sexuel d'accord je suis d'accord
[Applaudissements]
interview prise de tête
est ce que vous êtes favorable relations
sexuelles avant le mariage
c'est agréable mariage oui si les deux
personnes 60 ans faut pas forcer les
gens à se marier bien sûr non je sais
que oui oui oui
maintenant l'idée de la religion dans
une histoire d'amour j'ai encore du mal
à savoir pourquoi ça existe mais c'est
sacré le mariage ludivine c'est vrai et
j'ai pas encore pris conscience de la
sacralité de cet engagement
il va falloir je pense m'en va falloir
un sinon vous allez faire un mariage de
merde c'est vrai c'est vrai bien sûr
bien sûr à la mairie du 15e
est ce que vous êtes favorable à la
sexualité hors mariage favorable si
c'est vraiment un bon coup vous allez
pas de main morte là non je sais pas
j'avais pas mes conditions c'est un
mariage si c'est vous êtes marié votre
mari vous satisfait pas vraiment bon en
imaginant vous 30 réunion parce que oui
oui
jusqu'ici tout va bien imaginons c'est
une vue de l'esprit oui et vous êtes
prête à le tromper avec le premier bon
coup venu bon bon coup c'est pas
toujours le premier venu pour tester
avant on est des fois ça peut être le
23e favorable à la contraception à
l'avortement
puis l'amour à plusieurs
ben oui si tout le monde s'amuse à
sabbatique
attends au divorce bah oui c'est tout le
monde sent merde
il est adorable au suicide aussi
j'attends vers l'euthanasie
oui mais oui oui faut tomber viendra
quand même envie de me suicider vous
déjà ouais je pense que le losc côté de
la mort n'a envie d'aller voir le flop
c'est rien à voir mais a changé de ton
temps ya toujours une curiosité un total
exact avait tout autant que ce soit
d'autres encore mais il ya plus arrivé
au des moments de la vie où tir en très
grand danger
tu te dis tiens
ouais on est dans la merde ça va mal se
passer ça va finir mais en même temps il
peut-être que l'autre côté il ya un truc
formidable qu'on a dit il ya une dualité
à ce moment là et c'est un fantasme qui
peut être créatif aussi ou mortelles
favorables à l'euthanasie
oui voilà même quand les gens vont bien
parce que là ça pose plus de problèmes
nous avons au tonnage ouais j'avais des
prises de tête en bus pour vous je sais
pas j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit
encore super bien réglée éthiquement
parlant donc c'est un garde est pour
l'instant j'ai passé deux projets n'ont
même pas vu dans le jeu honnêtement vous
êtes favorable à la peine de mort pas
vraiment et la peine de mort pour les
assassins d'enfants
pas plus
je voulais vous dit rien ce que vous en
pensez ce ça dépend des jours non non ça
dépend des jouets c'est un jour où ou si
j'imaginais quand tu es quelqu'un de
proche de moi c'est pas quoi ouais
j'aurais tendance à souhaiter sa mort ou
même essayé de la provoc et moi même je
pense mais sur la philosophie qui
croient que tant qu'on n'est pas dans
l'immédiatement immergé en première
ligne sinon à priori je pense pas que la
peine de mort résolve grand chose si
c'était se débarrasser de façon
définitive de quelqu'un qui vous a été
hostile
ce qui n'est pas obligatoirement une
mauvaise manière non plus donc ça dépend
des jours la nuit pour mardi ou mercredi
jezzine jusqu'à midi jeudi vendredi
je suis contre l dimanche quand je
m'emmerde vraiment je peux le redevenir
est ce que vous êtes favorable à la
peine de mort pour ceux qui sont pour la
peine de mort n'est toujours pas au
droit de vote pour les immigrés ah oui
c'est important ils sont condamnés à
mort pour rester dans la thématique
bah oui c'est important que qu'ils aient
un tout petit pouvoir de pour voter pour
des gens qui règlent leurs droits c'est
évidemment aussi non pourquoi le vote de
quelqu'un qui est là depuis six mois
qu'il n'a aucun intérêt commun avec toi
le problème c'est la communauté
d'intérêts qui donnent la droite la
communauté de vote donc un hymne y est
là depuis un an ou deux ans à quai dans
un système auquel il est dans lequel il
est contraint de vivre comme nous tous
le vois pas pourquoi on ne demanderait
pas son avis sur des choses tout à fait
penser en fait tu es contre le droit de
vote pour les touristes viennent
d'autant qu'il est je veux pas qu'à
roissy t les flics la douane les urnes
non c'est tout faux que le maigre est un
peu est ce que vous êtes favorable à la
réouverture des maisons closes
elles sont pas déjà ouvertes
ça va comme ça c'est aussi simple que ça
c'est le bordel retient que le dirigeant
américain
bahram eric je trouve ça assez sans
finalement d'accord ouais je sais pas
c'est dans le programme de quels
candidats savaient pas béraud et capote
au colza est favorable à la légalisation
du cannabis
plutôt ouais voilà ludivine sagnier
dans 8 femmes
soie rose
[Musique]